please be aware that the following video
contains images and discussion of
physical assault and as much as i'm
aware that i am about to become part of
the problem i would encourage people to
look into the winners of last night's
oscars as their work and their accolades
are being overshadowed by the
controversy surrounded by the night's
events this would include amongst others
openly queer actress ariana debose deaf
actor troy kotzer and questlove whose
documentary summer of soul is probably
being the single most overshadowed thing
in the wake of everything going on i
would encourage you to look up their
acceptance speeches and look into their
work
and that having been said i will now
become as i noted part of the problem
so in the past i've done everything from
talk about oscar nominees talked about
the show after it happened talked about
winners
i even uh live streamed a reaction to it
i think i did that last year
and
this was the year i honestly thought you
know what i don't really need to talk
about the oscars i looked at the list of
nominees realized i hadn't seen hardly
any of them didn't want to see most of
them didn't have strong feelings about
too much of it and figured i can skip
this year's oscars it's fine
but then
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
well the oscars aren't actually about
the oscars anymore
[Music]
so at
the academy awards
chris rock was presenting
the oscar for best documentary
and
being chris rock he came out and he
started doing some jokes
and being chris rock he singled out a
few people in the audience and
had a little fun at their expense
and
whatever you think of any of the
individual jokes told this is kind of
par for the course it's not uncommon for
the oscars in general or for chris rock
in particular
who has presented at the oscars before
but then something different happened
he made a joke
directed specifically
at jada pinkett smith and it related to
her hair now we'll take a closer look at
the joke in a little bit
but
he made that joke
and that seemed to be the last joke he
was going to do he's prepared to move on
but then
will smith jada pinkett smith's husband
very famous
actor in television film famous as a
rapper and uh later the same evening
winner of best actor for his role in
king richard
walked up
and slapped chris rock across the face
and then went back to his seat
from which he proceeded to yell keep my
wife's name out your
mouth i'm going to and
there is literally
no conversation about the oscars
other than this
right now
this
was bonkers
here's the thing
i don't actually want to talk about the
event itself all that much
for a number of reasons the big one
being i don't
actually know
how i feel about this
but a big part of the reason that i
don't know how i feel about this
is due to all the stuff that i do
want to talk about what i want to talk
about is the conversations that are
happening around this event the
different framings the different angles
that different people are coming at this
from and the way in which it is very
quickly twisted and morphed into
something
far bigger than a single incident
and
this has been
kind of nuts to me
because
look i'm not on twitter
nearly as much as some of my peers here
on youtube
i'm not used to seeing this play out in
real time i'm not used to seeing
huge swathes of the trending page to be
about this one single thing just coming
at it from different angles
i'm not used to watching that unfold
and it's kind of fascinating i think in
many ways illustrative
of the ways in which people bring
their own unique perspective
baggage and sometimes biases
to a topic
and
i can't believe i'm actually going to
say this
politicize it to their own ends
because
so much of the online discourse right
now it is spun off in so many disparate
directions and i'll be going over a lot
of them
that has to do
with what people
actually want to talk about and so they
take this incident
and use it to springboard
into something else altogether
even the people more or less sticking to
the topic have gone on some wild
tangents and
conversations and threads have gone all
over the place
and this is by no means going to be
comprehensive like i'm i'm recording
this the day after the entire thing
happened and i'm going to try and have
this out one day after that so two days
after the thing happened this entire
discourse will already have mutated
multiple times by the time i get this
out so don't come here expecting a
comprehensive overview
this for me
the value i'm trying to extract from
talking about this
is mostly just
this
kind of
weird
strange
multi-layered discourse
train wreck
is a big part of why it's actually hard
to talk about these topics at all
and is actually why i
don't really have a personal take
because while i don't think every angle
that people are approaching this topic
from is valid
a number of them are at least i feel
like are fair to factor in and the more
things i factor in to the overall
picture of this the less i'm like i
don't
know how to feel about this
but
to the extent that i am going to be
comfortable doing it
let's talk
about the incident in a bit more detail
so
chris rock's joke
his joke was to imply that jaden pinkett
smith would be starring in gijn
ii
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
that joke for context if you don't know
g.i jane
that was a film from the late 90s in
which demi moore appeared and at this
point is probably most famous for the
fact that she shaved her head for the
role
so him making that joke towards jada
pinkett smith was a joke about her
shaved head
now
that
broadly speaking
without getting into more context which
we will get into is
an okay joke
it's about the appearance
of a celebrity
and
generally picking on celebrities is
usually considered punching up
and not generally considered to be
punching down
however
jokes at the expense of medical
conditions
is usually considered punching down the
thing is jada pinkett smith's shaved
head is not a fashion thing she has a
condition called alopecia and she had
been battling hair loss for a very very
very long time until she finally just
said to hell with it and shaved her head
and owned it and that's what she's been
doing for a little while now
so for him to make a joke
highlighting her shaved head
whether intended or not whether he knew
this about her or not
you can have a completely separate
discussion of over whether he did or
didn't know this about her but we
honestly don't know most people might
think well everybody knows this about
her i mean like yeah if you follow this
stuff but i don't know that he does yes
he lives in that world that doesn't mean
he knows everything that goes on with
everybody but regardless whether
intended or not the joke
becomes a joke at the expense
of a medical condition and it's
generally at this point kind of
considered bad form to pick on that
i mean except among you know people who
kind of make their career intentionally
poking the bear
and arguably chris rock can be that kind
of comedian
i will say i do personally feel the joke
was in poor taste again whether he fully
appreciated that or not i don't know
i see other people talking in very
definitive terms that he must have known
but
i don't know if that's true i'm not
comfortable assuming but it's not a joke
i'm gonna defend i don't think it was a
joke in good taste
and one more tiny bit of context about
that is that if this isn't if
if
he did know about her condition
and
if he knew that her shaving her head was
yes her choice but a choice heavily
influenced by something she had no
control over
that
becomes a bit worse when you take into
account that he helped produce a
documentary about black women's
relationship with their hair and how
important that relationship is it's a
documentary called good hair he helped
make that happen
so if he knew that that wasn't just a
fashion choice
and he made fun of a black woman's hair
or in this case her lack of hair
that's
wow
wow
now chris brock has taken shots at both
jada pinkett smith and will smith
he's done so at the oscars for that
matter it's not fair that will was this
good and didn't get nominated yeah
you're right it's also not fair that
will was paid 20 million for wild wild
west okay jaden boycott in the oscars is
like me boycotting rihanna's panties
i wasn't invited i don't want to put too
much weight on this because as i said
it's not like he targeted them
exclusively he makes fun of people
that's part of his routine can make
movies fast
every month
porno stars don't make movies that fast
but i feel like it's at least worth
bringing up because it's one more factor
that may have been in there where it
becomes less about a joke that a guy
told and more about okay i've put up
with stuff from you before i'm not going
to anymore was that the case was that
the mentality that will smith stormed
that stage with i have no idea but it is
something that's in the mix don't know
for certain
but that is some of the contexts that
some people are upset at chris rock
about so that's the joke
now let's talk about will smith
so uh will smith
initially as the camera shows
laughed at the joke jada pinkett smith
did not
she
rolled her eyes very emphatically the
footage then cut back to chris rock who
as i mentioned before tried to get
things going with the show again
when
will smith walked up and slapped him
and the raw anger
being displayed by smith from the
footage of when he was sat back in his
seat and was yelling and swearing at
chris rock is in very stark contrast to
the footage of him laughing just seconds
before
we'll dig into this particular element a
bit later when we start talking about
the discourse but i want to highlight it
now so that you understand
this is going to come up again and
having now
uh made a call about the joke which i
don't think was a particularly good joke
the slap
i'm certainly not comfortable having
watched it
like at all
but
i feel really uncomfortable making a
definitive stance on that and if people
are about to say oh you're not prepared
to condemn violence you're saying
violence is okay no i'm not saying
anything right now because this is
complicated and twisted up as we're
going to be getting into
i will say i was deeply uncomfortable
watching it
i
would vastly prefer that it had not
happened
that i will say
but i also have to freely freely admit
that has more to do with my own level of
personal comfort as a viewer and frankly
a white person
and i don't feel comfortable getting
judgy primarily on that basis because
that's the only real angle that i've got
on this that i have any certainty about
is my own comfort level
and i'm not sure my own comfort level is
relevant
it's also worth noting that
even after the slap after the swearing
chris rock
did continue the show
to the best of his ability dead silent
room
but he moved forward that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay so let's start looking at the
different ways that people
are talking about this
[Applause]
okay so first thing i feel i need to do
is tackle the idea that was asked when
it initially happened i presume largely
out of shock because it seems so
unbelievable
but i'm actually still seeing some
people claim that this was staged and
not real
which
makes no sense i don't want to spend a
lot of time on this because it's a
frankly ridiculous notion but staged by
who and to what end
if you're implying that the academy was
in on this and were fully aware of what
was going to happen why would they do
that this has completely diverted the
entire conversation about the oscars to
be about nothing but this nobody's
talking about the actual oscars anymore
that is not to their benefit not to
mention the oscars are supposed to be
the classy version of this i suppose
maybe the argument is they did it for
ratings except that it happened in the
middle of the thing it's not going to
suddenly get a spike in ratings the
people who cared about this were already
gonna watch it and the people who didn't
watch it at the time weren't gonna tune
in the moment's already over maybe they
would have gotten a little bit of spike
when will smith went up to accept his
award but the ratings weren't gonna
matter and it's not gonna roll over to
next year because the assumption is
going to be they're going to make things
so that this sort of thing isn't likely
to happen again not suddenly turn it
into jerry springer so if it's not being
staged by the academy as a whole it
would have to be staged between chris
rock and will smith but again
why chris rock isn't that kind of
comedian he's not andy kaufman he's not
known for pulling this kind of prank
like the only angle i could possibly see
this from is it's absolutely true will
smith for the last few years seems to
have been going out of his way to
dismantle his own image own up to things
he normally avoided and talk only about
things he didn't talk about before and
this certainly obliterated a lot of his
image in the public discourse but like
why the way in which he's been going
about dismantling his public image has
been through
conversations interviews the book that
he released through telling truth not
staging nonsense none of that makes
sense so we need to completely disregard
the idea that it was staged let that go
now the first thing that generally you
will find or probably the first thing
that started happening at least i wasn't
watching the entire thing unfold i went
to bed but
uh the first thing is that there is the
standard argument over
who was in the right but i suppose more
uh nuance is the wrong word slightly
different angle on that is the question
did chris rock deserve it
and if he did does that mean
will smith was right to do it
now
most people are intertwining those as
married points that they are
inherently together and while they're
they are related i think one of the most
helpful
notions i saw came from actually a
friend of mine who i saw on twitter
uh who tweeted out chris rock deserved
to be hit
and will smith should not have done it
now i'm not saying i agree with that
position as i said i
like i just feel really weird
i don't know
what i feel right now but
what i will say is that was a
particularly helpful tweet for me to see
because it reminded me of the important
point that
these
while nested topics but they're not so
joined at the hip that the answer to one
automatically determines the answer to
another
so
that's why i'm largely going to be
talking about these things in separate
chunks even as i get into the discourse
around them so
when discussing whether or not
chris rock
deserved it
is also a discussion about
was the joke okay
and if not
was any response warranted or all right
so there's obviously some people who are
gonna take the classic angle of
comedians should be allowed to tell
whatever jokes they want without
repercussions which i don't agree with i
never have i never will
i think comedians like any person have
the right to free speech to say whatever
they want they do not have rights from
consequences that is not to say those
consequences do or should include being
slapped by an audience member
but
the general tenor of the conversation on
this angle there are as i said the
people who will simply say he should be
allowed to say whatever he wants
which
like in life
sure
but
this is
supposed to be
the classy movie awards event
there is such a thing as appropriate
time and place regardless of right to
say something now that having been said
he does do this kind of humor he has
hosted at the oscars before
i think it's debatable whether or not
these particular bits that he did were
actually scripted i've seen some people
bring up the idea of look there's a
teleprompter these jokes would have been
pre-written the academy signed off on it
that's not necessarily true because
oftentimes when presenters comedians
especially start interacting with the
audience that's not pre-scripted because
it can't be they may know in advance
where everyone's sitting but they don't
know what people are gonna wear they
don't know uh you know exactly what the
general tenor of the night is so
generally that's gonna be a little bit
more loose as they make their decision
on the spot for who they're going to
pick out from the audience to say
something about now i'm not saying
definitively that was the case but i'd
be very surprised if it wasn't so i
don't think this is a case of a joke was
signed off on by a lot of other people i
think it was something that he said in
the moment that
obviously
backfired very badly but
unless i'm wrong
i don't think i am but unless i'm wrong
about that that does mean that
responsibility of the joke does lie with
chris rock even though the academy would
have placed him in that position knowing
the kind of humor that he does but
knowing that does not mean that you know
he was going to make fun of a woman's
medical condition
i don't think anybody i don't think
chris rock knew he was going to do that
until he said it
maybe he did but that's not the
impression that i have not from him as a
performer and just from the way the
oscars usually go
the people who are really heavily
scripted and teleprompted are the people
who are usually doing really
awkward banter between each other come
on anne don't be so modest
no i'm not modest i'm just not nominated
you can tell when it's scripted i don't
think that was
and that does mean that he holds sole
responsibility for the joke
now
this is where we start to get
the first layer of all kinds of people
getting pulled into this conversation
who have nothing to do with this
conversation when i say pulled in i
don't mean like they're weighing in and
maybe some of them have since i've shot
this i don't know but at the time of
recording they're being pulled in
because
everybody is bringing in these other
topics that they feel are related or
making comparisons to other people to
the point that names that have nothing
to do with these names of people who
aren't there names of people who are
dead
are trending
so
what i mean by that is
people posted everything from
lookout ricky gervais
dave chappelle you're next asking things
like did frank sinatra ever hit don
rickles no of course not don rickles was
trending the man's dead just this
general idea of either would this have
happened to any other comedian has this
happened to any other comedian the
answers uh in the latter case definitely
be no and the other one spinning off
into its own conversation we will come
back to this is going to end up being a
long video this thing is a
hydra of a topic
but
that's the first thing and then the
other thing being
what if
people now start responding to comedians
like this are comedians now going to be
afraid is this going to have a silencing
effect because they're going to be
afraid they get hit
and
that's an odd conversation for me
because
i'm not
sure you'll have much luck drawing an a
to b comparison from will smith hitting
chris rock
to
some heckler in a comedy club
next week who causes a scene like
heckling happens stormy of stages
happens
it happens at awards shows
just
generally not at the oscars but i don't
see this as having much of a silencing
effect because
well
comedians who deal in this kind of humor
already had to worry about taking off
the audience
and they've already made their decisions
about how much they do or don't care
about that
this is an outlier of a reaction
so
that's an angle that i don't feel has a
lot of legs to it now in regards to the
question
would this have happened
if it was anyone other than chris rock
there is some nuance to that
one of the angles and this is again
another name that was trending one one
of the angles that people came at this
from was to bring up i bet you if it was
dave chappelle will smith wouldn't have
done anything that having to do with the
fact that dave chappelle
um has been working out lately and is
frankly a more intimidating physical
figure than chris rock is who's
kind of a scrawny guy
and then there becomes a question about
bullying there
would will smith have done this to
anyone who he didn't view
as being his physical inferior and i
don't know the thing is none of us do
and that's part of where
what's so weird and discomforting to me
about a lot of these conversations that
entire line of thought and all the
multitude of places it goes
depends on a reading of
will smith's mental state
and we don't know his mental state
and i will never be particularly
comfortable
speculating on the mental state
of
people involved in these things the very
rare times that i dip into any kind of
thought process about that it's
usually
in relation to a creative decision like
if somebody who's running a tv show that
i like makes a creative decision that
baffles me i might try and parse their
mental state in so far as why would they
think that's a good idea but not to the
degree that i'm going to try and
psychoanalyze them
which is a bit of a cottage industry
on twitter and also here on youtube
where people will take artists work and
actions and try and
diagnose them as
narcissists having abandonment issues
having this having that thinking this
thinking that like you don't know
you don't
so
understand that that whole line of
thought
spinning off from would he still have
hit it if it was somebody else that
spins off into a whole other thing
about
bullying physical intimidation and
conversations that aren't actually about
will smith's mental state but make a
hell of a lot of assumptions about it so
i'm gonna stop down that path but
understand it keeps going here's the
next thing i want to bring up
in terms of the way this is being talked
about and framed because this
i think might be the best example of
where
people see something
and they take an interpretation that
i can't say for certain isn't accurate
but they spin it to a very specific
political or social commentary end
and that has to do
with that flip from laughing
to storming the stage and slapping chris
rock because i said i'd come back to
this
initially
will smith was laughing and
again not to try and diagnose his mental
state the laugh didn't look
uncomfortable to my eye
it looked
genuine or at the very least
yeah fair
again i don't know his mental state but
that's how it read
so
then for seconds later for him to storm
the stage and slap him
you have to ask
what happened in those seconds
now here's the first thing to be very
very clear on
we don't actually know
i have not found anywhere and i've
looked that there is any footage
holding
on that shot of will smith and jada
pinkett smith
the footage that is available right now
is the footage that was broadcast which
cuts from the two of them back to chris
rock
and we don't see will smith again until
he's all already on his way up to the
stage
so
a lot of people
are asking
what happened
and again keep in mind we don't see the
turn
we don't see
what
happened
or even a change in expression on will
smith to know for certain what happened
i want to be clear on that because again
people are talking in insanely
specific and definitive terms about this
and this is where we start to get
discussions about whether or not
he felt he had to do it to quote unquote
defend his woman's honor and whether or
not that was an action he took on his
own or whether it was something that
jada pinkett smith in some way
prompted him to do
or if the nature of their relationship
is such that
she feels
that if she is displeased enough it is
his job
to act this way
maybe she feels that maybe he feels that
again no idea
but there's a lot of very uncomfortable
conversation around that basically a lot
of people are intending to paint jada
pinkett smith as a lady macbeth
character
that look he was fine and laughing she
was clearly unhappy
and the assumption again we don't see
this
but the assumption is
he laughed he turned back saw that she
was unhappy
then he got up now is that
a fair assumption
probably
i don't want to like cast so much doubt
to be like that definitely didn't happen
i'm saying
we don't know for certain that that
happened and so it makes me very
uncomfortable how definitively people
are talking about something that we did
not see
we don't know
if he turned to look at her
saw her reaction and then
flipped and changed his perspective and
went up
we don't know that for certain is it
very likely
yes certainly believable and
understandable but we don't know that
for a fact not unless the academy
releases a hold on that angle and we get
an unbroken cut from him laughing to him
getting up
unless that footage comes out we do not
know that for certain but let's talk
about this framing which is
being used to
make a lot of different points and
sometimes
disparate points
on the one end there are people who
appear to be using this to
demonize jada pinkett smith
as
the instigator of the incident
as someone who has poisoned him to act
this way
the one thing i am going to say about
that at this point is that that is
robbing him of any agency in his choice
to go up and slap a man now that's not
to say that whatever his pre-existing
relationship is with his wife may not
have influenced his decision to do that
but like the man made a choice he wasn't
hypnotized
but
the other side of this
is to dissect it as an aspect of toxic
masculinity another term that was
trending for a while
where the idea is that he is so
protective of her that he will resort to
violence
in order
to
defend her and protect her
which absolutely is in the broad sense
an aspect of toxic masculinity the role
of men in our society as protectors can
be a very positive thing but it can also
be twisted into
overprotective spouses boyfriends
fathers who resort to violence against
people in the idea that it's part of
their job as protectors
so
there's this conversation about
the evil that is jaded pinkett smith
and the evil that is toxic masculinity
perpetuated by will smith and then in
the middle
is the cuckold conversation
because the term cuck
was also
trending oh this is so exhausting okay
i feel like i have to explain this i
feel like most people know this already
but just in case
traditionally the term cuckold is a term
used for a man whose wife is having
affairs with other men
more recently it has taken on a meaning
within fetish and kink communities for a
relationship between two partners
where one of them usually the man or at
least that's the stereotype of the kink
not only has a wife or a partner who is
sleeping with other people it's
something that that person is aware of
and is consenting to
and who
gets off on it
that's what the kink is
more recently than that it has become
shorthand for an emasculating insult
basically well implying a number of
things implying that you're too weak to
control your woman implying that
you are getting cheated on and you're
too weak to do anything about it it when
it's used as an insult the implication
is that the guy isn't actually okay with
this he's just so ground down by his
partner that he agrees to it because
he's got no spine left and he's not even
a man that's how it tends to turn up
when used as an insult and it is being
used primarily in that context to refer
to jada pinkett smith and will smith
and this spins off into its
own freaking conversation
because of some relatively recently
realized things about their relationship
which is to say
faithfulness has not been a constant
with them now
the full picture and exactly what has or
hasn't gone on is
not entirely
clear i don't feel though again people
are talking very definitively about this
here is
so far as i understand what is known
jada pinkett smith
has had
intimate relationships with other men
while being married to will smith
he is aware of that and at this point
the public is now aware of that
they have remained together
whether or not will smith has had
relationships with other women seems to
have a slight more question mark
there were things sad and conversations
had where he clearly had an interest in
doing so with implications towards some
specific people such as halle berry who
was also trending as a result of this
and
there is it's a little bit less clear as
to how many of those things were
interests desires future plans or hopes
or something that had in some capacity
actually happened and also i couldn't
really find definitive clear-cut
instances of exactly to what extent
either or the other
had
talked openly with each other about this
that's not to say that like this came
out behind their back this kind of came
out about their relationship it seemed
at the time in a way that like they were
both just making the world aware this is
something we've been dealing with hey
it's me and the editing phase quick note
on this because i've looked into a
little bit more there is at least one
affair from halle berry which will smith
was not aware of prior to when it
happened due to miscommunication over
the fact that they were separated at the
time and it not being clear whether or
not things were going to reconcile that
was apparently a point of conflict along
the way and i guess there are
implications in will smith's book that
some of his extramarital affairs have
actually happened again i don't know how
much confirmation there is on that okay
back to it and they have framed this in
a way that indicates that it has been
an issue and a strain on their marriage
so
it's usually one's own opinion on the
ideas of monogamy
and how
strongly they hold that belief whether
they choose to frame this as
she cheats on him or has cheated on him
or whether they view this as a
dysfunctional polyamorous relationship
between two people who probably weren't
communicating with each other properly
and maybe should have done more research
into the general practice of polyamory
before trying to do some version of it
that clearly wasn't working at least
initially
i'm inclined to lean towards the second
given just the general tenor of the
conversation that the two of them have
had and also that some of the other
people who know and are close to them
have had to me indicates
at least an understanding that
neither one of them seems to be
perfectly comfortable with monogamy and
they're trying to sort that out
again
impression i don't know this
nobody knows this
for certain which again makes me very
uncomfortable with the certainty with
which some people are talking
but that's one more thing fueling the
uh the cuck
insult that is being thrown at
will smith
so
there's that angle
then
there's the bigger picture
and the meta context
and
so far as i
have been able to see
i'm not going to say this definitively
because this might have to do with the
sides of twitter i kind of deliberately
avoid
but so far
i have not seen much in the way of
people
actually trying to frame this as a
look this is the result of
violent black culture or dog whistling
the idea that black people are
inherently violent hey it's me again so
against my better judgment i did
actually check her on twitter a little
bit and uh yeah i know there are
definitely some people who are actually
saying these things either dog whistling
it or saying it flat out and uh before
anyone tries to nail me on this i did
check these accounts that i am
highlighting here and did see that this
is consistent with other things they've
said and they do not appear to be
parody or joke accounts or sarcastic
tweets this all looked sincere to me
so yeah
this is a thing too
and so we're dealing with
piled on top of each other
ideas of what kind of jokes are
appropriate should comedians be held
responsible what counts as a reasonable
way to be held responsible notions about
how people should react to an
inappropriate joke notions about toxic
masculinity notions about masculinity
monogamy and cuckoldry notions about the
images of black people in the greater
national conversation and
more than that
it's so
strange to me because as i said
this is not unique
what is happening here
happens a lot
when big events that everybody is aware
of happen
people start talking about it but they
don't just talk about the event they
talk about it through the lens of their
particular interests
viewpoint
and
often
will
if not
um
rework what happened at the very least
frame it
in a way that makes
their point
some of these points are more valid than
others as i said
but the fact that there are so many
and i do feel that some of them are at
least
worth having conversations about
at the very least having conversations
about the conversation
that's where
i'm just
left
floundering and don't really have an
opinion
i said at the start i wish it hadn't
happened
i'm not sure that's true
i will actually absolutely stand by the
fact i kind of wish that i hadn't
watched it and i feel uncomfortable
doing so but again like that shouldn't
be anybody's priority what i will say is
that the fallout of all this
has been really illustrative to me of
something that i see
talked about
but because i'm not so active on twitter
i rarely see happen
personally
which is
that this one event
serves
almost everybody's
talking points
if not directly
then having a hot take on somebody
else's hot take
will serve your talking points
i generally push back on the idea that
someone is quote-unquote politicizing a
topic
because first of all
everything is inherently political
everything is framed by the political
circumstances under which we live
everything carries inherent political
connotations there is no such thing as a
truly a political topic we can for
various reasons choose to treat them as
such and sometimes there's a value in
doing so but
politics are not injected into things
they
exist already
but that having been said
people do absolutely
have their preferred political lens
through which to view things now that's
not the same as injecting politics into
it as i said the politics are there
but what people do instead
is they put blinders on
and ignore the political aspects that
don't serve whatever point they would
like to talk about
i've done that
in this very video i've done that
because of my discomfort
my politically rooted discomfort in
making moral judgments of an incident
between two black men
i am instead choosing to put blinders on
to a certain extent and focus on the
discussion and the conversation
we all
do this and it's not an inherently bad
thing
i need a lens through which to view this
because as i hope the sheer amount of
stuff i've had to bring up has
illustrated there are too many angles on
this for me to take everything into
account and actually be able to process
it and then go about and have a
functional day
and i certainly can't do that for every
single freaking thing that happens
the blinders to a certain extent are
necessary
but watching the ways in which this
conversation has splintered off into
these fractal
frankly
troubling or
just buckwild side topics and tangential
issues and bringing in people who have
nothing to mel gibson was trending i'm
not even sure i understand why but i
know it was connected and another
completely random thing that is tied up
in all this the academy tweeted out that
they don't condone violence of any kind
which has led to some conversation
question about
are they going to take away his oscar
should they take away his oscar and
there's a whole other side conversation
going on about will smith's acceptance
speech and how weird that was in the
wake of the slap but i'm not gonna try
and dissect that thing i'm exhausted and
coming back to the tweet from the
academy that has turned into its own
freaking meme as people start throwing
all these things of oh does that mean
that you're no longer going to be
inviting or nominating or rewarding any
of these people giving a list of people
who have violent histories at some point
in the past that who either
have been invited to attend the
ceremonies or have been awarded since
those incidents and all this other stuff
and again it's this fractal mess that
just everybody brings in
whatever baggage they've got
and applies it to this
and again
i'm not trying to be dismissive some of
this is relevant some of these are
really relevant questions
but this thing is a snowball that will
not stop gathering
more and more
crap
the way that we interact on social media
in general and twitter especially it
creates a situation where
our blinders cause us to bump into each
other
a lot
and
to some extent that might even be
healthy because when you bump into
somebody
you become aware
of the blinders you have up and maybe
you reconsider are these helping me
should i be focused on exactly what i'm
focused on should i be taking other
things into account but then on the
other hand it can absolutely put you in
direct
contact with people that
frankly should not be in contact with
each other because it is toxically
explosive
but as other people have talked about in
other places
twitter's actually deliberately designed
to cause
drama and fracturing and arguments
because arguments drive engagement a
hell of a lot more than nuanced
conversation does which is why this
video will probably not do nearly as
well as videos in which people just give
their hot take on what was or wasn't
right
and who did or didn't do the right thing
or whatever else because when you
actually try and take this stuff into
account and as i said i've even been
doing this through a lens and with
blinders it's over freaking whelming
it's overwhelming to think about to
process to talk about
and probably to listen to
so if you have stayed through
to this point
thank you
all right one last time will smith has
at this point issued apology over
instagram i'm just going to acknowledge
it here i'm not actually going to dive
into this because as i said i wanted to
focus this conversation around
the conversation that's been going on
and i don't see the response to this
really changing anybody's mind from the
positions they'd already decided to take
up
so with that in mind
let's wrap it up this
i don't have a final conclusion
it's just something that i had to talk
about
to some extent
just to clear my head space
this is one of those occasions where i
kind of had to process on camera
i had to talk to somebody
so i'm talking it out with you folks
and if i'm very very very lucky i did it
in a way that maybe people will find
interesting
helpful
if i screwed this up i'm sure i'll hear
about it in the comments but
whatever your thoughts are and please
this is a hard rule
on this channel
no
personal attacks or insults towards
anybody you can talk all you want about
people's actions how you feel about them
etc
do not start calling people names
because i will delete them regardless of
what point you're trying to make you do
that and i will delete your comment
don't do it to me don't do it to other
commenters that's been an issue lately
and don't do it to any of the people
involved in this
so if you can
stick by those rules
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments and let's
talk about it
patreon is how i'm able to do this for a
living it's why i was able to turn this
around and get it out a couple of days
after it happened because
i can spend my work day doing this
instead of having to be in an office
somewhere
so if you want to help
that continue to happen patreon supports
the best way to do it i also have other
things down below other ways that you
can support me or other things that you
can follow me on like twitch
yeah twitter tiktok etc etc
um but
even beyond that like share subscribe
they do help
but
you know what after all this don't worry
too much about it if you can help it
because what i want you
to remember
is that as overwhelming as the world
gets sometimes
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
it's the end credits means i gotta shout
out some patrons this month it is turok
oliver b linda walters tt robin powell
fronabilax the poodle idoln tracy
scrabbon dharma michael doyle vincent
paul bartolucci angry casper adam lefty
taylor robin moore shayla gourlay and
bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]